please no
no not like this
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to
phasmaphobia in vr and phasma phobia and
vr is a very different beast
from phasma phobia on the desktop
according to
the phasmophobia developers on twitter
this is where [ __ ] gets real
what that means i don't know so this is
going to be different because i've never
actually gone out on my own
i don't actually have a good grasp of
everything that i need
because well frankly everyone else
always walked me through this so
without bob or wade here i'm kind of
gonna be well actually without wade here
i'm gonna be kind of on my own
i'm a little concerned because i have a
funny feeling i'm gonna die
and i'm gonna lose all my stuff but
that's okay because
i'm not gonna go for too difficult okay
intermediate
that's pretty good prison i don't wanna
go to prison
right now high school ah you know what
i'm gonna go to the house
i got a bad feeling about this oh
oh it's a different beast all right
discover what type of ghost we're
dealing with
detect a room with 10 celsius with a
thermometer capture a photo
of dirty water in a sink get a ghost to
walk through salt ghost is maria moore
maria moore maria moore more maria moore
this ghost also seems to respond to
everyone you should be able to use this
name to anger it
get some paranormal activity make sure
to refer to your journal
where's my journal how do i oh okay so
that's where the journal is
okay keep it on the evidence page
nothing yet
the good oh this is a different beast
okay uh this is serendipity because this
is actually the first video
or the first uh place i've ever gone to
on this one oh
god i fit my ass is towards you i always
got to make sure
i don't rotate in real life i turn in
game it's the only way i'm gonna be able
to do anything
okay oh wow
my belt okay oh
my belt let's definitely get the
thermometer oh
oh oh
ah how about in my dick no i can hold it
in my hand
i have two hands i have
hands i have hands i have
two hands look at me look at me
swinging my light around by the hips
okay so i got this i got this i'm ready
to go
i technically have two hands but you
know what actually i'm gonna come back
to that
all right let's do this baby okay
all right
oh it is very different oh yeah this is
very different
oh this is very different oh i don't
like this
hang on hello i need the key don't i
okay good that's fine
okay got it what is this supposed to be
anyway
this is a glow stick oh my god
hell yeah hey oh
hey oh my god
oh my oh my god no oh god no
oh god no oh my god
no no
no oh my god no
oh no okay i'm fine
i'm not that big of a [ __ ] all right
so i've been here before i know this
place and i know the layout
i just gotta find the room that's cold
and that's probably where the ghost is
gonna be
i gotta be very careful because i am by
myself and given that i'm by myself i
just gotta make sure
that i'm always cognizant
of the different threats i remember the
name but i'm not going to say the name
ain't going to say the name let me just
cue up a hidey hole right here
okay if i if i get in trouble i'm going
right over there all right
is anybody here
are you there okay
it's not on experts so it shouldn't be
spawning in it for at least another
minute or so
i don't know maybe right away what the
hell
oh it's a plant oh
oh i got the here why
hello hello
hello hello ho
hello hello hello hello
hello hello
oh no um
okay i gotta go get some more stuff
oh all right okay
okay hi matt sorry my ass i know as
appealing as it is to look at probably
not the best
let's try this again okay
okay okay how about you
am i you anything in here hello
someone's masturbatorium with a fapping
chamber
okay all right oh hello
oh come on do not tell me it's in the
basement do not tell me it's in the
basement
it would be it would be wouldn't it it
would be where are you
what are you doing oh light
oh
okay it's not cold here uh it's not cold
here either
it's not cold anywhere i've been through
this whole damn house
it's not cold anywhere i don't know
what's going on man i don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't know
oh wait no please not now no
no please no i don't want it no
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean in here
do you mean
oh no here where
ah oh this oh my god this is the room
okay this is the room okay let me drop
that here
do i see any hand prints nothing like
that okay i'm gonna assume not
okay i'm gonna go get more stuff oh
oh no
all right okay so there was some
activity on the radar there
that's good to know that's good to know
that's good to know okay i'm gonna bring
in a camera
uh the emf okay
oh sorry sorry sorry that's gonna take
some getting used to
i apologize i wish i could see the video
you know
on the camera that would be nice
why oh
oh god oh god okay
i'll put that there i'm gonna turn that
drop it
okay i'm gone i don't care about turning
i'm gone
uh-huh oh am i running i don't know if
i'm running
doesn't feel like running doesn't feel
like running
how do i run all right we're okay let me
check that camera real quick
okay not seeing any orbs
i don't see nothing it wasn't freezing
temperatures
that means the haunting's about to start
my sanity ain't doing too good
i get that i appreciate that next time
i'm gonna change it just to do the
smooth
turning because to be perfectly honest
the snapping is kind of getting to me it
goes to walk through salt
i'm gonna bring a gosh darn crucifix
that's for sure
and bring some salt okay all right
okay back off
everybody back off
back off back off
okay i'm gonna put it in the doorway put
in the
oh my god not all of it oh no that was
all of it oh god
oh no back off
take off we got nothing on the emf we do
not have freezing temperatures
do i have like something on the door no
okay all right you stay there i'm gonna
get more salt
oh my god no no no no no turn turn god
damn it turn
ah
i don't have any uh stick things incense
whatever it is i don't have that
okay i'm gonna guess this is not a thing
i'm gonna guess that this is a thing
i'm gonna guess that this is also a
thing put that there
put that there i'm bringing them up i'm
bringing this this ain't
this ain't not going don't want to kill
the batteries i'm bringing this
okay turn turn okay
[Music]
oh oh
are you here ah
oh no oh no
okay we have writing okay remember that
everyone remember that remember that
that's
that's important that's what they call
important
ah were you trying to lock the door on
me
were you trying to lock the door on me
oh yeah i got the salt that's great i
don't know what the salt's supposed to
do
at least we have something we have uh we
have book writing
got basically nothing else okay no ghost
orb definitely no ghost orb
okay activity's been very low which is
good no emf
yet unless i need to kick it up a notch
i don't know the only other thing i
gotta do is take a picture of dirty
water in a sink but i don't even know if
i'm gonna get that
i don't even know if i wanna get that
the rest of my material is in there i
think i just gotta make it mad
hopefully this can stop it i don't know
do i gotta throw this at it i don't
remember i didn't do this before
i might as well be a paparazzi about it
all right let me just i'll bring this
just in case
back off [ __ ] back off
[ __ ] [ __ ] back off
[ __ ] back off
back off back off [ __ ]
[ __ ] back off back off
back off [ __ ] back off
back off back off oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no
okay oh no no no no
no no no no no oh no no no ah
i'm fine that's only going up to a three
that ain't doing nothing
okay oh
oh oh badge
batch okay we're still not freezing
temperatures
still no ghost orbs so what are you
maria moore
maria moore oh
oh oh oh
oh
this is fine
[Music]
oh no
oh no oh no
oh
where'd my flashlight go oh no
no
okay i think i'm gonna go for it i'm
going for it
i'm going for it oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god come on oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no it's happening now oh no
oh no oh no back off back hopefully
[Music]
welcome back there's some jobs ready for
you well
the cross didn't work hey but i leveled
up okay
good great good man that's that's good
stuff man that's that's really good
stuff
um all right that was good that was good
that was good stuff let's go to the
grafton farmhouse
i'll add in my thermometer that's pretty
much the only thing i need
thermometer goes sorry ready up and go
all right good professional this is what
i was hoping for
and that last round went about as good
as i could have hoped it could
it was pretty good i was actually very
happy about that
okay no reports of violence or sightings
for that matter so that's okay
i've never actually listened to that
before usually people are jabbering in
my mouth we got susan jones
discover what type of ghost we're
dealing with cleansing area with smudge
sticks
prevent ghosts from hunting with the
crucifix detector's presence with a
motion sensor
well i didn't bring that i brought
nothing
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
just look for the cold spot and i'm
going to go for it
and as soon as this activates we are
going
which is great all right let's go ahead
and do this combo all right
what's the worst that could happen it's
just a ghost
just a silly old ghost hello
hello what was the name again i don't
know i don't care i'm not gonna say it
hello is anybody in here i guess i might
as well turn this on
is anybody there is anybody here
anybody home oh i hate this i hate you
you crotch the old [ __ ] just gonna go
ahead and open up all these doors
get myself some trouble hello
hey i hate it turns out i hate it
nelly i hate it i hate you
i hate all of it i hate you you
little [ __ ] don't think i won't smack
you in the next century
i'll do it i've been known to do it and
i'll do it again
oh oh
i'm not gonna pick up that phone i hope
you know that i hate you
i hate all of you i hate you
why's it gotta be so squonky oh oh
what did i just do what what
here what
where he oh maybe
hello hello oh
oh no in here this area
oh oh yeah okay all right okay
here
no i'll leave that there is anybody
there
can you give us a sign show yourself
i'm not getting anything on there let me
go get the emf reader
oh i hate that i hate this and i hate
everything i hate all of you
everyone's a [ __ ] in this house except
for me i'm a big manly man with huge
balls but get out of my way i need a lot
of space
for my balls so i'm gonna look for
that get this ghost orbs and then emf
okay
all right this should be professional
actually wait oh
wow hey
dick
hey oh
hey get out of here
hello
what in the fresh hell was that
why you think you can just giggle
are you not in this room am i in the
wrong room am i in the wrong room
are you in that room and one way to find
out
is anybody there are you there
no can you give us a sign
it's definitely a whole lot of nothing
on that can you write in my book
can i have your autograph can you touch
a door handle
do you have cooties are you a big cootie
monster
how many cooties do you have how did you
get soaked
how did you get some maybe it was this
room was it this room
no no
no no no no no no no no it's this yeah
it's
almost freezing temperatures almost all
right there's got to be something here
this can't be nothing yeah no it's cold
okay i'm gonna look for ghost orbs this
is harder than i remember it being maybe
i didn't actually do any of the work
maybe it was the other guys
maybe they did everything and i just was
running around like an idiot getting
killed
i have a funny feeling that's true but
i'm going to deny it for as long as i
live
never tell any of them that they're
better than me because there probably
are but i don't want them to know it'll
go right to their heads
susan jones okay that'll be a good idea
let me shout his name that'll be good
my sanity is low but whatever susan
jones
susan jones susan
jones don't go storms oh it's always
going to come down to this i got to go
antagonize it or something i don't have
any defense mechanisms
i'm kind of boned i came in here with
nothing
okay here i go again here i go
professional ghost hunter let me at
least take a pic before i
die
susan jones susan jones
susie jonas please be nice to me
oh no please be nice i want to be your
friend
be my friend be my friend be my i'm
we're going to leave now i'm going to
leave i'm going to leave i'm going to
leave
i'm just going to go be my friend all i
ask is that you be my friend
okay well i got this if i freeze temp
i'll go
white in the mouth man this one's not
very active only responds when you're
alone well i'm the only one here
so i'd think that it would respond but
it don't
oh was that a ghost or wait was that i
thought i saw oh i think i did
that might have been just the hint of a
ghost orb i think it just across the top
there
oh oh oh oh was that a bug
was that a ghost the orbo whoa
that was a ghost storm okay that was a
ghost storm definitely definitely go
storm okay
could be a yuri could be a shade shy
ghost
okay hard to find could be a shade if it
is a shade what am i looking for
emf ghost orb ghost writing okay maybe
let's try to get something out of it it
said that no violence was detected so
i'm assuming it's going to be very nice
to me okay the orbs seem to be coming
from over here so let me let me actually
place it uh
maybe on this chair actually it might be
good okay so we're looking for emf
i don't think we're looking for
fingerprints but you never know let me
just keep this on me actually
come here give give give give give
come on what the hell oh ah
there we go oh my god no no no no no no
no no
susan
susan jones susan jones
please
oh no please
please no no not like this
[Music]
susie why god oh
my body ah i'm dead oh
well i think the moral of the story is
that i'm very not good
at this especially by myself trying to
get evidence
when you're alone means that you need
all of the defensive items that you
possibly can
but also i should have just put down
shade just in case it
was but hey that was fun yeah i gotta
say
the future is now when it comes to vr
besides the headphones a completely
wireless experience that was pretty cool
i like that a lot i'll try that again if
you guys want it
it's a different beast playing it by
yourself i i could get better at it i
definitely could but that is
an entirely different thing when you're
by yourself but
super fun like i gotta admit that's
terrifying i i kind of want to find
other people that are also doing it in
vr
uh to see what they can do but you know
that is something else
so uh yeah let me know in the comments
if you want to see more of that thank
you everybody so much for watching
leave a like if you want to see more and
subscribe if you do want to see more and
expect it in the future
who knows when it'll come by again but i
want to do a lot more scary vr games
because i sometimes forget that that is
really what makes things terrifying
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you